monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres
j'aurais aimé ne pas avoir à reprendre
la parole dans cet hémicycle
après une nouvelle frappe de l'islam
radical malheureusement l'histoire
bégaie après paris après nice après
magnanville après saint-etienne du
rouvray
après strasbourg après marseille après
carcassonne après toulouse après trèbes
c'est au coeur d'un service anti
terroriste comme islamiste a tué nous
pensons bien sûr aux quatre policiers
lâchement assassinés à leur famille et à
l'ensemble de leurs collègues en deuil
et le président de la république parle
de bâtir une société de vigilance elle
c'est à dire qu'il entend exonéré sa
propre responsabilité et qu'il veut
faire porter injustement une part de
responsabilité aux français or ce qui
s'est passé dans la préfecture de police
c'est la longue dégradation le compromis
la chape de plomb que fait peser dans
l'espace public
le politiquement correct ce n'est pas en
jetant à la figure de ceux qui
s'inquiètent du désarmement moral de
notre société et de sa
communautarisation l'adjectif
islamophobe que nous gagnerons cette
guerre c'est au contraire en renonçant
et en ne tolérant plus aucune
manifestation aucun signe de ce qui
conduit et annonce la radicalisation des
esprits que nous nous protégerons vos
mots ne suffiront ne suffiront plus et
ce sont vos actes désormais qu'ils
seront jugés
alors monsieur le premier ministre allez
vous vraiment vous attaquer au terreau
de l'islamisme et à toutes les formes de
communautarisme
[Applaudissements]